a teenager hit and killed by a bus on
boulder highway surveillance video
shedding some new light though on the
last night's deadly crash the last
moments of that crash the boy does not
appear to even slow down before impact 8
news now reporter sally jadamia was live
near boulder highway and indios avenue
where it all happened and sally do we
know how young that boy was
denise that 16-year-old boy known as
oscar sanchez his family describes him
as a sweet boy who loved video games and
football and this is where it all
occurred last night oscar's older
brother says he was on his way to
walmart
walmart's is a distance and at 10
o'clock at night i was sad because i'm
like i wonder if i know the kid you know
christina eggman says this all happened
right in front of boulder food mart
where she has worked for 17 years eggman
says she's seen so many tragedies on
boulder highway yesterday was one of
many we're always looking it's like
you're
sometimes paranoid because of the bombs
and the rough people an employee on the
night shift saw the crash he looked out
to check around make sure nobody creepy
was out here he looks he sees this kid
flying
and he said within a second he jumped
from the counter to come out because all
he could see and
was the bus
grab him from the corner and drag him
down the street metro police say shortly
after 10 o'clock last night surveillance
video shows oscar riding a stand-up
electric scooter on indios avenue they
say he ran a red light and was struck by
a bus christina says scooters shouldn't
be on busy streets my kids had them when
they were little my grandkids got them
they go 25 miles an hour they're not
safe
they should be in a remote area maybe in
a skate park or a field or desert where
they got paths not on the sidewalks her
message to parents and drivers tonight i
just advised that they watched the kids
on the motor scooters
back out live i've been in touch with
the family they say a kindle live vigil
will take place in about an hour for now
reporting live from boulder highway
sally jaramillo live local now